this [ __ ] is bananas be a na na yes now
seriously has gone down hey Ron i'ma be
sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen if
you've been following my channel you
probably noticed that one of my most
popular videos my what I eat in a day
review of freelee the banana girl's diet
had been taken down and I got a lot of
questions and concerns about where this
went and what was going down well let me
tell ya there was a little bit of drama
happening behind the scenes okay so let
me tell you the story so back in
February when I was on holiday I got a
notification from YouTube that I had a
copyright strike filed against me and
copyright strikes have huge implications
for our channel so rightfully so we were
quite worried about this and of course
who filed the copyright claim freely
hurt so yes so we decided to go through
the process of appealing the copyright
strike and after ten days having no
response from our dear friend Leanne our
video was reinstated of course and if
you haven't watched the video yet you
can check that out right here if you're
curious what all the kerfuffle is about
so let's take a look at the final tally
where we are so far
so before afternoon even hits freely has
eaten scratch that has drank two
thousand two hundred and forty calories
seven thousand five hundred twenty seven
milligrams of potassium five hundred
ninety grams of carbs and this hit
almost five hundred grams of sugar guys
these numbers are crazy unbalanced now
listen I am NOT here to be a YouTube
bully but as a dietician with a public
profile I really feel like it's my my
duty to call out this problematic
behavior and I get that I being a little
bit abrasive in the past with freely and
I've really tried to tone it back in my
more recent videos but I feel so
passionate about this because I've lived
this life I have a history of disordered
eating and I see her diet as so
disorderly and it's almost like a
northrax yeah how to I feel like it's so
problematic I
need to say something and my concern is
that you know she's got so many
followers so many people watching her
videos following her way of eating I see
a whole slew of youtubers that have kind
of come out of this world from her and I
want people to know that for the vast
majority of you watching her this way of
eating is not going to serve your body
well not physically or psychologically
that's for sure it's not about the
veganism I wholeheartedly believe that
you can easily incorporate a plant-based
diet into your life and do so in a
really really healthy balanced way but
freely is not a testament of that as a
dietician youtuber I feel like I have
these competing priorities of me not
wanting to critique or shame people for
their diet because hey what feels good
for you feels good for you and that's
great and freely if you feel great
eating this way I am so happy for you I
mean I'm not going to yuck someone
else's YUM that is how it works that's
what intuitive eating is all about but
when a youtuber comes across as being so
prescriptive of the way that they eat
and being so dogmatic that it's so
religious about it I have to step in
because they see as a public health
concern and this is a public health
concern we have skyrocketing levels of
disordered eating happening and
personally I can definitely attribute a
lot of that to the rise of these social
media influencers when it comes to all
of these highly restrictive diets and I
I have to say something now what I've
learned through being thrown into this
whole world is what a toxic environment
the Wellness space is online especially
on YouTube honestly it's like high
school all over again and freelee's the
bully that nobody wants to stand up to
and props to those who have stood up to
her I mean this is not free Li's first
legal rodeo you know I take my role as a
dietitian very seriously I think I have
a lot of responsibility as a public
profile Rd
and this is not the first time that
Frehley has attacked another dietitian
for calling out the diet that you
promotes I am the proof that it is
working and so are thousands of women
around the world and it is sustainable
and I have my blood tests online do you
have your blood tests online showing
that you're extra healthy no I don't
need to actually know that's the thing I
mean enough had obese nutritionist try
and tell me that my diet is wrong and
I'm like hey just cuz you got a bit of
paper doesn't mean I'm gonna take your
advice so honestly I'm quite surprised I
haven't seen a response video from her
yet I'm going to be doing a video very
shortly about what I've learned in the
kind of vegan YouTube space which I feel
as though there's a lot of bullying
going on there's a lot of judgment a lot
of kind of like holier-than-thou
happening where like one person's not
vegan enough for the other person like
who cares I've kind of been watching a
lot of these videos and these critique
videos to get a sense especially of like
freely style because if you watch
freelee's videos and you like look at
her channel there's a lot of these like
clickbait titles like why I'm no longer
vegan why I'm vegan again then she's got
some what I eat in a day videos then
she's got all these critiques of other
people and a lot of them are like her
calling out people for eating meat and
then other ones are her calling out her
like vegan brothers and sister youtubers
who are not vegan enough apparently so I
have no qualms with this format but just
don't be a hypocrite about it because if
you look at what she filed against us it
was a copyright claim but she uses this
format all the time all youtubers do it
is totally legit and kosher in the fair
use terms so I just find it really
interesting that of all the things she
could ding us on it was a copyright
claim for a format that she uses
consistently in her channel and listen I
am like navigating this space myself and
learning as I go and yeah I was totally
way more harsh with freely than I have
been more recently because I'm I'm
trying now to look at the specific diet
rather than kind of critiquing the
individual so
freely I'm sorry you're pissed that I
called you out on your dangerous
disorderly content but if you're gonna
Bellini like you believed everyone else
on YouTube you're gonna have to deal
with actual science and reasoning and
not just copyright claims and to all of
my awesome viewers the good news is that
we are back in business here at Abby's
kitchen Collin temple and making awesome
videos backed up by science and staff so
guys I hope you enjoyed this video if
you have some youtubers what a new day
videos to review definitely leave me a
comment below or keep it a list of them
and there's a lot of diets to get
through so definitely leave me a comment
I will get to it eventually like this
video and subscribe to the channel I
will see you next time on Abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]
[Music]